I'm not there apparently I'm still
downloading a map for some [ __ ]
reason it's okay mark it'll be on my
team
[Laughter]
yeah three two one we got it right the
first time
this map is amazing yeah it's really
nice watching booyah oh I don't think
that's gonna help you what a good angle
[Laughter]
what if you went in the other corner
though oh okay thank God you killed all
those Cowboys like your friend so right
here yes I think that's pretty good yeah
if I turn does it show me turning no you
you're sad okay good good do you have a
very particular what is your set of
skills Scottish is he uh Irish isn't he
northern I give us I don't know who you
are but I have a particular set of
skills now it comes out of Solid Snake
doesn't have the same appeal
Wego what people call me on the Internet
[Laughter]
isn't that he's in the corner no it's in
the corner holding I'm in the bigger
building I'll give you the baby if
somebody put baby in the corner Oh
somebody put mark in the corner yeah
someone put me in the corner I put me in
the corner but did you say so you know
how it's a duplex that he's in one room
and he exists there but there's not a
version of him in the other is a
fantastic hint yeah that's wrong hint
for two and a half minutes cuz I knocked
it over we're coming for you take in
your game yeah you well I can feed her
her feet right up against my face well I
mean I can come touch your face with my
heart no no it's too risky
oh alright Bob I don't see him I think
we're being made a fool of I think we
are getting towed I think you're doing a
very good job of that in your own yeah
you don't know me oh wait wait a little
risky yeah oh wow I didn't know that
opened well there's a basement damn
losing health there's a lot of two pairs
of items I thought I'd get here we're
all surprised as a basement you still go
down there shooting dang it Bob we are
being straight-up made a fool of I think
we're just really bad at this guys are
you guys in in a bush or some [ __ ] we're
just really tiny objects that's mark
there's hands where I don't know where
but they're cams stop running your lives
Bree those where'd he go where'd he go
oh you're out the back door yeah sure
damn it Bob I lost them I tried to do
that to Jack it didn't work all right so
Wade was McDonald's fries
Jack while I was a Big Mac challenge
back I lost him I threw my grenade right
at him he didn't blow up it's totally
black jack no we won we won so I think
we can have the round here because we've
won technically I got him play video
who's still a prop right now
may I yeah it's just like waves like we
won but just a technicality marquees
over here in my building okay I'm coming
which building oh [ __ ] you door jack us
[Laughter]
in the exact same place I should have
killed him by a chair is not fair at all
I have an idea Bob well you do your
thing I have an idea for me not for you
[Laughter]
[Music]
feeling there in the basement we're in
the basement oh no oh why why God why
son of a [ __ ] shoot find them wait what
is it you wait am i not taking damage I
shouldn't have panicked when the grenade
went off I thought I was dead you know
you know Odyssey I can't tell which one
of yours so it's probably good all right
this was on purpose and good luck oh no
wait never mind Bobby you don't look
you're levitating off the ground never
mind okay down you look fine
Oh excellent can you not move Bob no
like okay move just stay right there
multiple stories wait if you give me if
you give me another prop here I will
show you the best hiding spot in this
map yeah mark mark you ruin it last time
I kind of [ __ ] everything up so yeah
mark ruined it last time but I know
where it is cuz I ruined yeah mark is
the one who screwed the whole thing up
so he knows exactly what I'm talking
about right out from under there's a
chair outside yeah
[Laughter]
well they say a bird in the hand is
better than two in the bush okay I feel
so bad for you did you seriously not
just see me watching from an eagle eye
view and no one move around
he's a lobster around the back porch
crab was moved in the beginning about so
much we weren't looking at your bushes
unless mark was she said the bush
as you said you looked at my weight did
you go downstairs no okay basements open
yeah I opened that I'll tell you that I
open oh yeah I don't give a carp oh god
[Laughter]
I was just like yeah he's a fish but
he's not in the fish location okay
Magikarp where are you something smells
fishy around here that jokes already
been made Jack you yeah Myers douche bag
anymore
yeah oh that's what you are okay that
makes more sense all right I got it
no scoot out just a little bit from
there all right that's good yeah it's
good all right Marky give us a clue
looking at give you I already gave you
all the clues moved and so apparently it
wasn't very good man he's escaping on
the railroad that's oh yeah I forgot
there's actually a train over there not
that not that at all that's the
underground part is this please do Jack
without the basement I'm in the basement
I'll go down better Oh Jack you fool
what you fool I'm saying you're fool
five you just gotta break everything
[Laughter]
presence was felt why did you give him
basement
I was gonna say railroad but you didn't
understand that so I had to say the
underground part I did not forgot there
was a train I didn't see the Train I was
thinking of something else okay my brain
works in mysterious ways that you don't
understand just thought you guys know oh
[ __ ] three seconds no Jack so much
[Music]
the smallest jump ever and